BECAUSE HE DIDN'T WANT TO.
THIS IS A SCARE WORLD.
THANKS, TUCKER.
WELCOME TO "HANNITY."
FORMER CONGRESSWOMAN TULSI
GABBARD IS NOT THE ONLY PERSON
LEAVING THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY
WITH A LESS MONTH UNTIL THE
MID-TERMS.
DEMOCRATS ARE MEMORRAGING
SUPPORT FROM THE
AFRICAN-AMERICAN AND HISPANIC
COMMUNITY.
AND INDIANA JENNIFER GREEN IS
HERE TO RESPOND TO A HORRIBLE
SMEAR CAMPAIGN AGAINST HER.
SHE WAS SEXUALLY ASSAULTED AND.
DR. PHIL WILL JOIN US ON THE
CONTROVERSIAL SHOW HE DID ON
CANCEL CULTURE.
>> WATCH WHAT YOU SAY.
THERE IS ALWAYS SOMEONE IN
PERSON OR ONLINE WHO WILL TELL
YOU, YOU CAN'T SAY THAT.
>> Sean: DR. PHIL WILL BE IN
HERE A MOMENT.
FIRST ANOTHER DAY AND ANOTHER
SCANDALAL FOR GEORGIA SENATOR
RALPHAEL WARNOCK.
HIS EX-WIFE POINTED OUT HE IS
A GREAT ACTOR BUT DOESN'T APPEAR
TO BE A GOOD PERSON.
A NEW AD WITH NEWLY UNCOVERED
BODY CAM FOOTAGE SHOWS A
A DISTURBING LIGHT ON ELIZABETH
WARREN AND HIS EX-WIFE.
WHY WASN'T ELIZABETH WARREN
ARRESTED?
>> [SOBBING].
HE JUST STARTED BACKING THE CAR
UP.
I COULD NOT BELIEVE HE WOULD RUN
ME OVER.
I TRIED TO KEEP THE WAY HE ACT
UNDER WRAPS AND TODAY HE CROSSED
THE LINE.
HE IS A GREAT ACTOR.
HE IS PHENOMENAL AT PUTTING ON A
REALLY GOOD SHOW.
>> Sean: WHEN ALLEGATIONS ARE
MADE, OFTEN THERE IS AN ARREST.
WHY WASN'T RALPHAEL WARNOCK
ARRESTED?
WHY DIDN'T THE COP AARREST HIM.
WHY IS THE MEDIA IN GEORGIA
COVERING FOR ELIZABETH WARREN?
THAT WAS NOT ELIZABETH WARREN'S
ONLY RUN IN WITH THE LAW.
HE WAS ORDERED BY A SUPERIOR
JUDGE TO ATTEND MEDIATION AFTER
HE WAS ACCUSED OF FAILING TO PAY
CHILD CARE EXPENSES.
AS A MINISTER ELIZABETH WARREN
WAS  -- WARNOCK WAS ARRESTED.
ONE TROOPER SAID I NEVER
ENCOUNTERED RESISTANCE LIKE
THAT.
WARNOCK WAS NOT CONVICTED OF ANY
CRIME BUT FIVE FACES OF CHILD
ABUSE WERE BROUGHT AGAINST THE
CAMP DIRECTOR.
THIS IS WARNOCK'S CAMP.
IF THERE WAS HERSCHEL WALKER,
THE MEDIA WOULD DEMAND ANSWERS.
ONE SAID A COUNSELOR TOSSED
URINE ON A 12-YEAR-OLD BOY.
HE WANTS TO END-ALL CASH BAIL
AND VOTED FOR TAX INCREASES
USING A LOOP HOLE TO NOT PAY
TAXES.
A PASTOR WHO WANTS NO
RESTRICTIONS ON ABORTIONS AND
PRAISES FARRAKHAN AND PRAISED
CASTRO.
THE DEMOCRATIC SENATE CANDIDATE
IN PENNSYLVANIA IS NOT ANY
BETTER.
NEVER WORKED A JOB IN HIS LIFE.
JOHN FETTERMAN MIGHT BE WORSE.
A LIFELONG DEADBEAT SOCIALIST.
A STROKE LEFT HIM SEVERELY
DISABLED.
IT WAS ON FULL DISPLAY ON NBC
TONIGHT.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> WE HAD A MONITOR SET UP SO HE
COULD READ MY QUESTIONS.
HE STILL HAS LINGERING AUDITORY
PROCESSING ISSUES.
ONCE HE READ THE QUESTION HE IS
ABLE TO UNDERSTAND.
HE STILL HAS SOME CHALLENGES
WITH SPEECH.
KATIE, JUST IN SOME OF THE SMALL
TALK PRIOR TO THE INTERVIEW
BEFORE THE CLOSED CAPTIONING WAS
UP AND RUNNING, HE HAD A HARD
TIME UNDERSTANDING OUR
CONVERSATIONS.
WE ASKED FOR MEDICAL RECORDS AND
FOR INTERVIEWS WITH HIS MEDICAL
TEAM.
THOSE REQUESTS HAVE BEEN DENYED
TO NBC NEWS.
>> Sean: EVEN MSNBC IS RAISING
CONCERNS.
WE WISH FETTERMAN A FULL
RECOVERY.
THE U.S. SENATE IS A BIG JOB.
THE VOTERS OF PENNSYLVANIA
DESERVE TO SEE FETTERMAN'S
MEDICAL RECORDS AND FETTERMAN
NEEDS TO TOP HIDING FROM DR. OZ.
HE REFUSES TO DEBATE HIM UNTIL
THE LAST WEEK OF OCTOBER.
JOHN FETTERMAN IS NOT MENTALLY
CAPABLE EVER DEBATING.
OF DEBATING -- TAKE A LOOK.
>> SHOULD JOE BIDEN RUN AGAIN?
>> THAT SHOULD BE A DECISION
MADE BY JOHN BIDON.
>> Sean: JOHN, WE ARE WRONG,